The Indian Child Welfare Act turns 40
this year, but it may not live much
longer. The law passed as an attempt to
ensure that American Indian kids weren't
being taken away from their families on
account of poverty or sheer bigotry. It
says the preference for adoption of
Indian foster children must be given to
Indians, regardless of tribe, even over
the objection of the children's
biological parents, and even if that
child has formed a years-long bond with
non-Indian foster parents. It was a well intended law that now protects the
interests of tribes over those of
children, creating a separate but unequal
child welfare system that leaves Indian
children in foster care far longer than
children of other races, and keeps
families of all races from adopting
children they have loved and cared for. A
federal judge in Texas recently declared
the law unconstitutional, a violation of
equal protection and federalism, and the
Supreme Court will likely take it up as
a result. It's about time. All kids
deserve a loving stable home. It's time
to stop treating Indian kids differently.
Do you think American child welfare
policies are fair? Let us know in your
comments. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.